the article was about and this segment
will be about body composition both uh
how well and how accurately it can be
assessed and uh what you should or
shouldn't do with the information that
you might glean from a body composition
assessment uh the reason I thought this
was an important topic to discuss to
write an article about and now to talk
about on the podcast is it seems like a
lot of people put a lot of value and
weight on the numbers they get from a
body composition assessment
um you know like I see a lot of people
who set goals like you know I I want to
be able to walk around at 12 year round
or like I want to get below 20 body fat
or whatever
um or you know they they put a lot of
value on quantifying their body comp
before and after a bulk to try to assess
exactly how much muscle they've gained
over like the prior six months or
whatever so so people seem to put a lot
of value in in these numbers they use it
to guide decision making to evaluate how
well a recent diet went or how much or
how well a recent training phase went
um
so I think it's worth
just discussing in Broad terms like
should you do that
um and and the the short answer is no uh
and the long answer is the topic of the
segment so first things first when
talking about body comp
um it's it's first worth asking like
what is actually being measured so Eric
as the actual body comp expert on the
podcast if you wanted to actually
measure human body composition
how would you have to do that that would
technically be done via a post-mortem
dissection yeah and a chemical analysis
of the tissues removed all right so
um which I've never done by the way for
the record yes uh that is good to know
so uh do you know of a way to actually
measure body composition in a living
human subject I do not that's good I
don't either just wanted to make sure I
wasn't sharing lies with people so yeah
if you actually wanted to get your body
comp measured you would have to be
dissected which I assume most people
don't want to do so uh any any way that
you go about trying to assess your body
composition is just going to be an
estimate based on other things so it's
first worth asking just kind of in Broad
terms what is actually being measured
when you have your body composition
assessed and
in what way are those measurements
actually associated with body
composition so
um there are several popular methods
someone might use to go about assessing
their body comp just kind of to go down
a list uh kind of in Old School one like
that used to be considered a yeah not
exactly gold standard but like silver
standard measurement that people used to
use quite a lot back in the 70s and 80s
still exists not quite as popular
anymore is underwater weighing or
hydrostatic Wayne what's actually being
measured there is uh displacement of
water via the the Archimedes principle
like assessing how much you weigh on
land versus how much you weigh
underwater to then estimate how much
water you're displacing once you have an
idea of how much water is being
displaced you roughly know your body's
volume and from there if you know your
body's mass and volume you can estimate
your body's density and since lean mass
tends to be more dense than fat Mass you
can use total body density to estimate
body composition uh the bod pod is is
more or less just an updated version of
underwater weighing it works on very
similar principles
um it's actually measuring changes in
air pressure within a confined chamber
but it's more or less doing the same
thing like you measure your body's
weight you estimate your body's volume
via the bod pod and then it's the same
sort of deal like if you're less dense
it's assumed you have more fat if you're
more dense it's assumed you have more
lean mass
um some other popular methods are skin
fold calipers and ultrasound
so with both of these essentially what
you're doing is you're measuring the
thickness of subcutaneous fat at various
points in the body and then it's just
kind of assumed that if you have more
subcutaneous fat you also just have more
fat elsewhere particularly visceral fat
so you just essentially roughly estimate
total uh body fatness from measurable
subcutaneous fat thicknesses uh probably
the most commonly used method for
assessing body composition and quite
frankly one of the worst if not the
worst is bioelectrical impedance
um which essentially what what happens
there is you make skin contact with
electrodes uh if if you've gone to a gym
a lot of gyms have these little devices
where you just hold the thing out in
front of you and it passes a current
like through your arms uh also a lot of
smart scales have bia technology built
in where there's little electrodes that
you stand on passes that electrical
current through your feet
um
and essentially the more total tissue
you have the more it will impede that
electrical current but in particular fat
impedes the electrical current to a
greater extent than lean mass does so if
the Bia device sees greater total
impedance it just assumes you have more
body fat
fun little story about bioelectrical
impedance well two funny stories yeah um
one of them was that one of my uh
previous professors from undergrad
he drew the Short Straw among the grad
students back when he was in school and
they were trying to see how much they
could fool a Bia device just by messing
with hydration within a single day yeah
and like I said he drew the Short Straw
so they got him more dehydrated than you
would advise in a controlled setting and
measured and then just you know said all
right drink up as many fluids as you
want Gatorade water Etc and just within
the span of it of a day his body fat
percentage reading went from just
absolutely shredded on one side of the
spectrum to like very very very high
body fat percentage like a lifetime's
worth of fat gain or fat loss within a
single day yeah uh another anecdote was
so Greg you remember when we were
teaching at UNC we had the little Bia
devices
so when we were learning how to use
those in kind of a big group setting I
had just competed a couple weeks prior
in bodybuilding and this is this is like
2013 before I actually like knew
anything about dieting and more
importantly what to do after a diet yeah
so like dude I just ballooned up after
this competition it was at the point
where like you know if I would take off
my socks at the end of the day I could
still see like them imprinted on my legs
like my body was just like a weird like
water balloon you're like lean healthy
active don't actually have any vascular
issues but you sh you still probably
should have been wearing the compressive
socks that people wear on airplanes yeah
it's a very strange like temporary
physiological state where you're just
like why do my lower legs look like I
have like severe heart failure right now
I don't know uh probably not a good
thing not recommended but yeah like you
know my body just didn't know what to do
with all all these calories water
retention Etc and but like I had already
gained uh I don't know how many weeks it
was since my show but I already gained
like from my stage weight easily like 15
pounds and I I do the thing do
everything according to instructions
like 5.4 body fat I was like well you
should have seen me 15 pounds ago you
know when I was when I was apparently
two percent body fat like yeah of course
it was just nonsense but yeah you got to
be you got to be careful with those
things well yeah I mean so
um when when I was teaching that same
class like there was uh like one of the
other outfit instructors
um who who was like in another program
didn't have to take any like body comp
related classes for for his major or
whatever
um you know like when we were learning
about how to use those devices like we
all use them uh had had Bia ass or body
comp and this guy like this guy was lean
like he he had a visible six pack like
wasn't like sub 10 but it was like
comfortably sub 15
uh the Bia device said he was like 27
body fat and he started having like a
small meltdown an identity crisis yeah
and like me and some of the other
ex-fizz kids had to go over to him and
be like look like they're not going to
teach you this in sports management but
like these devices are fake like you
don't you don't need to worry about this
yeah
um but yeah so uh moving on uh there are
several popular methods of assessing
body comp they basically just use body
geometry so there's a formula developed
by the US Navy back in the day uh
they're simple weight to height ratios
and now they're like fancy high-tech 3D
body scanners and all of these methods
work on the same general principles
where
people people whose bodies have a
particular shape uh the shape of their
body tends to be at least somewhat
indicative of how much fat they're
storing so like in particular if you
have a particularly large waist
circumference relative to how tall you
are or relative to limb circumferences
that's generally indicative of storing
more body fat like that that's the
general principle that that these things
work on
um
and then finally uh there is dexa dual
energy x-ray absorptiometry
um which look like very high-tech
machines because they are
um but essentially what they do is they
pass uh very weak x-rays through your
body and essentially try to assess how
much energy is being absorbed by the
X-ray and the way they convert that to
an actual body comp estimate is is
pretty interesting so your bones will
absorb more energy than any of your
other tissues your lean mass will absorb
less than bone and your fat mass will
absorb uh less than lean mass will and
essentially that will create a little 2D
printout where your bones show up like
in in kind of the unfiltered way bones
are very white lean mass is like a mid
gray and then fat Mass is like a very
very dark gray because it's not
absorbing as much energy essentially the
darker something is the the less energy
it's absorbing
um I know there are some devices now
that will make like very colorful
printouts from that same information but
uh it's the same general principle and
essentially then there's just an
algorithm that counts pixels
um that
looks to like basically roughly quantify
like how dark or light a particular
pixel is and then sort it to say like oh
that's a bone pixel that's a lean mass
pixel that's a fat Mass pixel
um and that's that's more or less how
dexa assesses body comp so those are the
basic methods like those are I think all
of the popular methods that someone
would use to estimate their body comp
what is actually being measured how
those things relate to body composition
um but it's worth noting as as we've
already like partially touched on that
all of these methods have uh you know
potential confounders that that make
them not just like one-to-one perfect
representations of actual body
composition so like for for example with
hydrostatic Wayne or the bod pod
um like the the formulas that feed into
those just basically assume that
everyone has the same density of their
fat mass and lean mass which we know in
in many cases to be
um
like not a true assumption so like the
the density of the lean mass component
uh can can vary between races I think
the density of the lean mass component
tends to decrease as age increases uh
hydration levels can affect things so
there there are a lot of little things
that can kind of throw off that
relationship between body density and
body composition and there are even some
things that are more uh more practical
rather than theoretical that a lot of
people don't know about if they haven't
been in a lab so like can you exhale all
the way yeah like a major issue with
underwater weighing people say well how
hard can it be measure on land measure
in the water easy enough well you have
to get every bit of air out of your
lungs that you possibly can otherwise
you're altering your underwater weight
and a lot of people freak out and then
even after you exhale you still have
some residual volume in your lungs how
can you measure that well you can't yeah
you just have to make an estimate like I
I forget what the actual value is but
there's like some number where it's like
okay if if someone exhaled all the way
we're just going to assume they still
have this amount of air left in their
lungs do they actually have that precise
amount of air left in their lungs who
knows but we just hope that they do yeah
and with bod pod Greg you walk in with a
beard like that a lot of air that gets
trapped in a beard that's true can be
tough to deal with yes
um
so so yeah like those those are some
things that can affect like bod pod and
underwater Wayne we've already touched
on Bia like basically anything can throw
off the Bia estimate in bad mood yeah
like I'm sure like if if it's like
Saturn rising or something yeah like
whatever we could probably come up with
a shorter list of things that don't uh
deleteriously affect Bia measurements
um but then for things like uh US Navy
formula wait wait to height ratio 3D
body scanners
um you know like people have differing
Regional fat storage patterns that could
throw those things off like uh
particularly well for all three of those
formulas waist circumference is taken
into account if someone just stores a
lot more subcutaneous fat than visceral
fat all of those things are going to
underestimate their body fat percentage
uh and then with dexa
um like you know basic things like
hydration are you adequately fasted
those can throw off dexa estimates but a
big factor is just that you're
extrapolating 3D estimates of body
composition from 2D images and I think
you mentioned this that on average about
40 percent of the pixels will have some
bone in them and since bone is is like
the brightest indicator on a dexa scan
it absorbs the most energy in pixels
with bone in them which again is like 40
percent of your body
um you just like can't estimate the the
fat or lean mass that is above or below
those bones just because the bones
overpower everything else so
um even though Dex is very high tech
like there there are still some like uh
basic extrapolation issues with deriving
body comp estimates from those 2D scans
yeah that's always the the thing you
tell people and they're stunned because
dexa is expensive and it gives you know
bone density metrics people think you
know oh this has to be ultra precise
there's probably minimal if any
shortcomings then you say yeah well what
we do is we stack up these pixels and
then before we even begin counting we
lose half yeah almost and people are
like holy [ __ ]
for real yeah I mean yeah this once bone
is in the pixel like a pixel can only be
one thing and the bone just gets thrown
away basically for that purpose yeah so
um moving forward uh now that we've
actually talked about what's actually
being measured when you're assessing
body composition uh and we acknowledge
that any any assessment is just an
estimate it's worth asking how accurate
reliable and precise are these estimates
and there is a lot of research that you
could point to on on this
um and in the show notes we'll link a
seven part article series by James
Krieger that that goes into this just
kind of Technology by technology just
citing a lot of research that looks
specifically at the accuracy and
reliability of all of these methods of
assessing body comp I'm not going to go
through all of the research like one by
one for each method because then I'll be
I'll be staring down another 90 minute
segment and quite frankly that would be
boring as [ __ ] but in in Broad terms
um most methods of assessing body
composition work pretty well for groups
so if you you you know recruit 20 people
and
um you know put them through any of
these methods of assessing body
composition and it says that like the
mean body fat percentage for this group
of people was 22 there's a very good
chance that if you then like if the
Declaration of Helsinki didn't exist in
like the Nuremberg code didn't exist if
you could just like kill these people
and dissect them and actually measure
their body composition their actual like
mean body fat percentage would probably
be somewhere between like 19 and 25
percent so like on a group level even
things like Bia do a pretty good job at
estimating average body composition for
a sufficiently large group of people
um
and the same is true for assessing
changes in body composition like if uh
after a 16-week training intervention
it's found that you know body fat
percentage has decreased by five percent
and lean mass has increased by two
percent in a group of people with most
of these methods of assessing body
composition they'd say oh yeah like body
fat percentage decreased by some number
between about three and seven percent
lean mass increased by some number
between about two and four percent like
there there can still be some small
group level errors but they tend to be
like two or three percent at most so
like for research purposes most of these
methods work quite well some of them
work better than others like for example
dexa is just categorically better than
Bia
um but you know for assessing groups of
people they all get the job done the
question is more about
I assume well you know dear listener
it's worth asking yourself this are you
a a person or are you a group of people
if you're a group of people you can you
can just uh skip ahead to Eric's segment
if you're a single person then it's
worth asking like hey does the relative
accuracy of these body comp devices
apply to me uh like what what are the
sorts of errors that I can expect when I
have my own personal uh body composition
assessed
and
uh my basic position and what I hope to
convince you of is that for an
individual most of these methods for
assessing body composition are
if not entirely worthless far less
informative than I think people
naturally assume and I think that comes
from essentially conflating group errors
and average errors with like individual
errors so for example if you're looking
at research on say dexa
you will find that the just the mean
error for a dexa assessment of lean mass
or body fat mass or body fat percentage
compared to a gold standard measure
which is usually some some sort of four
compartment model
um the average error is generally like
less than two percent it's generally
like one like between zero and two
percent give or take so like essentially
if the group level average with a four
compartment model is like 18 body fat
dexa might say it's 19 and a half
percent or something like that so some
people look that look at that and say oh
well
dexa overestimates body fat percentage
by one and a half percent so if I get a
dexa done and it says I'm 14 I know to I
know that that means I'm like 15 and a
half percent but boom like it's it's
that precise number if the mean
overestimate is 1.5 percent that means
my personal overestimate will be exactly
1.5 percent add that on Boom good to go
uh or people might look at things like
uh like average absolute error typical
error
um which for dexa for example is like
two and a half three percent uh and
that's that's like a plus or minus so
for example if if there's two people and
dexa overestimates body fat percentage
by two and a half percent for one of
them underestimates by two and a half
percent for the other the average error
is zero percent the average absolute
error is two and a half percent
so it's slightly savvier people will
will look at that and be like oh like
the average absolute error two and a
half three percent so if dexa says I'm
15 body fat that means I'm somewhere
between like 12 and 18 body fat which is
a bit of a range like people might
interpret 12 and 18 to be considerably
different but you know that that is
still like a somewhat tight range and
and they look at that and say oh just
plus or minus the average absolute error
um boom good to go uh relatively tight
range
however I think that if you're
you're an individual uh again like if
the average absolute error is
three percent or something there are
going to be errors for individuals that
are smaller than three percent which
therefore means if the average is three
percent there also have to be errors
considerably greater than three percent
uh and so
I think that if you're an individual
it's worth asking what what is the
largest error that I could get from a
particular method of body comp
assessment and if you want to be
slightly more charitable like what is
the magnitude of error that I at least
have like a decent chance of getting you
know like a 20 25 chance of getting an
error of at least this large so
uh to illustrate this point I I made
some synthetic data that like mimics the
accuracy of of dexa very well so like
with dexa the average uh the average
group errors are pretty small like
generally less than two percent the
average absolute errors tend to be like
two and a half three percent so I I made
a pretty little scatter plot that
conforms to those those specifications
where the average uh the average error
between actual body fat percentage and
an estimated body fat percentage is only
half a percent and the average absolute
error is 2.7 percent so if if you're
watching on YouTube you can you can see
the scatter plot here with a nice little
regression Line running through it you
can see it's a nice tight relationship
uh the R value like describing the
strength of the correlation is around
0.9 which again is around what you see
for high quality methods of body comp
assessment like for example dexa and you
might look at this and say like hey you
know if if this is representative of the
accuracy of dexa scans I feel pretty
good about that like it seems to track
pretty well with people's actual body
fat percentage
but now again if you're watching on
YouTube we'll uh we'll throw a a
histogram up here showing the frequency
of
estimation errors of different
magnitudes and so a lot of people are
are going to be getting pretty small
errors like less than one and a half
percent so you know for a non-trivial
amount of people if dexa says like hey
you're 19 body fat you know you might be
20 you might be 18 but like it's it's
going to be pretty close
but then there are also like a pretty
large number of people with errors in
the three to six percent range like
larger but not like way way larger than
the average absolute error where if
you're getting up to six percent that
means Dex is saying you're 20 body fat
anywhere from like 14 to 26 which like
I think you could figure that out pretty
easily without going in for a dexa scan
and then for like a a decent number of
folks like in excess of 10 of
individuals you're gonna get errors
larger than six percent up to about ten
and a half percent which you know one
once you're dealing with individual
errors in excess of ten percent that's
just a roll of the dice that's a random
number generator uh and is is almost
entirely uninformative
um so like that these are the types of
individual errors that that we're
looking at
um when
as when assessing how useful body
composition estimates are for
individuals I
kind of a rough rule of thumb if the
average absolute error like whatever
it's reported to be
there's a a pretty decent chance like
you know like a better than 20 chance
that the actual error that you see
um or that you could get from your body
composition assessment is like twice as
large as that so if you see that uh you
know the average absolute error for
hydrostatic weight like let's say it's
four percent or something like that that
means there's a pretty decent chance
that you could get errors up to about
eight percent even though the largest
possible errors would be even larger
than that so uh just as just to kind of
like ground us here and I'll note that
that this kind of simulation was to
illustrate the sorts of Errors you could
see for assessing body composition at a
single point in time this same principle
applies to assessing changes over time
as well so like if a particular method
of body comp uh analysis says that your
body fat percentage decreased by eight
percent but the average absolute error
tends to be of like a similar magnet
attitude so like that decrease of eight
percent could be anything from like a
decrease of two percent to a decrease of
fourteen percent like it's it's the same
type of range like this is a
generalizable principle
um
so like here's here's one little
illustration to
um just like
Hammer home this point with with uh like
like in illustration that I think will
just like make intuitive sense to people
so uh let's say you recently completed a
diet you started at a body mass of 100
kilograms about 220 pounds and you cut
down to 80 kilograms or about 175 pounds
and you got dexa scans done before and
after your diet and dexa said you went
from 30 body fat to 20 body fat so
ultimately what we're asking here for
like the usefulness of body composition
assessments is like
what can you do with that information
how should you interpret it
um you know can you use that to say that
your diet was relatively successful or
not so if you take those numbers at face
value and just assume that like dexa has
zero error for estimating body
composition uh those numbers would imply
that over the course of the diet you
lost about 14 kilograms of fat mass and
about six kilograms of leaten mass
and I would say for most people that's
kind of an ambiguous outcome like that's
certainly a lot of fat to lose your body
fat percentage decreased by 10 percent
but if you if you're someone who does
resistance training like you probably
worked pretty hard to gain those six
kilos of lean mass in the first place
and that might feel like quite a lot of
lean mass to lose over the course of the
diet so you know that's kind of a mixed
bag
but then let's assume very
optimistically that the individual
errors produced by these dexa scans are
up to about five percent which like
that's an incredibly charitable
assumption so if we look at it through
that lens uh instead of your body fat
percentage decreasing by exactly 10
percent it may have decreased by up to
15 or by only five percent
if it decreased by 15 from say 30 to 15
body fat that would mean that you lost
18 kilos of fat and only two kilos of
lean mass which I think most people
would interpret as a virtually
unqualified success like you preserved
virtually all of your lean mass lost a
ton of fat I think almost anyone would
be very very happy with that outcome uh
but if the if dexa underestimated your
loss of body fat percentage uh and it
only went down by five percent that
would imply that as you lost 20 kilos
you lost 10 kilos of fat in 10 kilos of
lean mass which I think most people who
who are engaging in resistance training
are interested in preserving lean mass
Etc I think most people would interpret
that as like basically a catastrophic
failure so essentially like if if this
scenario played out you lost 20 kilos
dexa said your body fat percentage went
down 10 percent
even with like a very charitable
assumption about this sort of individual
areas you can get from dexa scans
essentially what it would be telling you
is that the outcome of your diet was
somewhere between unambiguously good and
catastrophically bad which I think you
could figure out without going in for
those dexa scans like that's essentially
like the entire range of body comp
changes you could have seen uh are
compatible with those dexa scans you got
um
so yeah like it's it's
I I think just far less informative far
less precise produces far larger
individual level errors than I think
most people realize
yeah I mean I've had clients in the past
who uh have said hey how often do you
think I should get my body comp tested
and I Say Never And they say well
there's this dexa place in town do you
think I should go and I say no uh unless
you're really interested in learning
more about your bone density in which
case Sodexo could be nice for that but
yeah there have been so many instances
where I'll I'll talk with a client and
say like
you know best case scenario this scan is
going to tell us what we already knew
worst case scenario it's going to be way
off and we're going to go with what we
already know to be true anyway and just
say wow that was a crappy scan yeah and
and so within that context it's kind of
hard to justify now I I agree
wholeheartedly I I think for most people
most of the time
getting your body compassed like even
via dexa is less informative like tells
you less explicit information about how
a bulk win or how a cut went then just
like seeing how you look in the mirror
assessing how your clothes fit feeling
how you perform in the gym like
uh
I just think those things for most
people most of the time tell you more
about the relative success of a bulk or
a cut than any method of body comp would
be able to for sure uh so
moving on I also want to briefly touch
upon an issue with Bia that I think a
lot of people aren't aware of like so
folks with smart scales that like if you
sand on them for long enough they'll uh
give you an estimate of your body
composition day to day there's this
assumption that I've seen repeated
multiple times like by by a lot of folks
in a lot of contexts that like yeah yeah
like I I understand that each one of
those measurements could have tremendous
error it could be way overestimating or
way underestimating my body fat
percentage but the changes over time
especially if we Trend them out should
be reliably predictive of what is
actually happening happening with my
body composition so you know if uh if
like maybe I'm actually 20 body fat but
my scale says I'm 35 body fat like
there's a huge error ultimately that's
fine because if I get down to 10 my
scale will say that I've gotten down to
25 percent and I know I'm not 25 body
fat but it should accurately reflect
over time that my body fat percentage
decreased by 10 like that's that's like
an assumption that I think a lot of
people have
um
but like that's not a good assumption to
make in a lot of context uh in in part
because of of how Bia actually measures
what's going on so as I mentioned before
essentially what Bia is measuring is the
impedance of electrical currents and
lean mass impedes electrical currents
less than fat mass does but it does
still impede those electrical currents
so if you have simply more tissue even
if your body composition hasn't changed
dexa will think you've gained body fat
uh and if you like if you lose a lot of
tissue again even if your body
composition hasn't changed dexo will now
think you're leaner like that that's
just how those measurements work
um and so like for example if you had an
astoundingly successful uh like uh
what do people say now gaintain or main
gain
what whatever I don't know it doesn't
matter if if you if you have if you have
a nice lean bulk and let's say
man it went better than you could have
even conceived of like maybe you're a
new lifter and you put on
10 kilos of muscle in your first year of
lifting without your body fat percentage
changing at all you go from like 70
kilos at 15 body fat to 80 kilos at 15
body fat you just put on a ton of muscle
your Bia scale would say you got fatter
like and you simply didn't but now like
your legs are more muscular there is
more tissue that tissue will impede the
electrical current your scale is passing
through your legs to a greater extent
than than they did before training so
like the the issue with Bia or like I
mean there are tons of issues with Bia
but like in underappreciated issue of
Bia is the fact that it is sensitive not
just to changes in body composition but
two changes in total mass
um to to an extent that I think people
just like don't realize so if you're if
you're using like a smart scale to track
changes in body composition over time
the problem is that
the information it's giving you can be
like not just uninformative but like
actively misinformative over time in
some context where like you could be
getting leaner but it says you're
getting fatter it says you're getting
fatter but you're actually getting
leaner because like total tissue mass is
increasing enough so like
even for purposes of like tracking
changes over time trending it out uh
like Bia scales can be like fully and
actively just misinformative over pretty
long time scales
so uh moving on
I think that
um
I think that it's worth taking a step
back
and just asking ourselves like why why
you would want to assess body
composition in the first place and I I
wouldn't be surprised if
uh
some percentage of listeners at this
point feel slightly slightly unmoored
and adrift because
you know they've they've had their body
composition assessed multiple times in
the past they they have previously put a
lot of value on those numbers they get
from those assessments and they feel
like well I I was doing this because
it's important like I need to know this
information to know how my pursuit of my
goals is going like you know like how
else am I supposed to know how well my
last ball went how well my last cut went
um you know maybe I'm trying to lose
body fat to uh be better at whatever
sport I compete in like I need to be
able to measure my body fat percentage
to know if that's going well
um
and I would I would like to push back
against that impulse like I think if we
acknowledge that we really can't know
our body composition all that accurately
or precisely on an individual level
um I don't think we actually lose
anything because I think more often than
not
most people don't actually care about
body composition goals that much they
they just assume sometimes quite
accurately the changes in body
composition should be predictive of or
associated with the actual changes
they're wanting to see
um but but I I would argue that most of
the time you can assess like a more
direct measure for the outcome you're
interested in than body comp would give
you so like for example
if you're an athlete and you want to
maintain muscle mass while losing fat
for the purpose of improving performance
in your sport
um you know you might think well I
should get my body compassest pre and
post off-season training to see if I
actually did that but the thing to keep
in mind is like you're doing it for the
purpose of improving performance in your
sport and generally there are going to
be tests you can do to see am I
performing better in my sport or are
there like proxy measures for
performance in my sport that are just
way more directly informative than body
comp assessments so you know for for
most like team sports Field Sports like
are you faster can you jump higher is
your change of Direction performance
better uh or just like you know like
let's say you're playing basketball like
if you're running scrimmages or pick up
games like are you getting more buckets
are you getting more rebounds like that
tells you how your performance is doing
and also like you could lead yourself
astray by potentially focusing on this
proxy measure for performance body comp
instead of performance itself so for
example like if your training volume is
quite High uh and you're really
attempting to shed body fat you could
just spend an entire off-season under
fueling yourselves for workouts and
practices
um and you know successfully lose the
body fat you are wanting to but wind up
performing worse like
because you weren't actually able to
train for your sport the way you need to
um so yeah like I I would argue that in
most of those contexts like even if your
goal like even if like a sub goal is to
try to change your body composition for
improving performance in your sport
if your performance improves it doesn't
matter quite as much if your body comp
actually changed and it's very likely
your body comp could change but that
could still be counterproductive because
of what you had to do to accomplish
those changes so yeah I would argue that
in a situation like that you're better
off just assessing sport performance and
seeing if that is improving
um another example like
a lot of people who are very interested
in assessing their body comp with with a
high degree of frequency and regularity
are primarily interested in Aesthetics
like they're trying to build muscle lose
fat achieve a certain physique a certain
look uh and so you know they they want
to get dexa scans every six months every
quarter to see how that is going
but I would argue that for those folks
like your goal is Aesthetics like
take progress pictures look at yourself
in the mirror from time to time uh and
like if you look bigger and you look
leaner
um does it really matter if a dexa scan
says you gained two kilos versus three
and a half kilos of lean mass or if you
lost two percent versus four percent
body fat like I I don't like if if your
goal is ultimately an aesthetic goal
like
Aesthetics are about how you look assess
how you look like that's much more
direct feedback about how the pursuit of
your goal is going than a dexa scan will
give you and I think part of that is
also just uh almost a linguistic or
communication issue like people use a
body fat percentage value as a shorthand
way of conveying a particular physique
look like broadly so you know someone
with a cut might say I want to get down
to nine or ten percent body fat and you
can kind of piece together what that
generally means and say okay yeah I know
what you have in mind yeah or they might
say no I want to be bodybuilding
competition ready we got to get down to
five percent the reality is neither of
those of those people actually care what
their true genuine body fat percentage
is
or they shouldn't what what they're
really trying to do is just give a kind
of shorthand summary of here's the kind
of leanness that I have in mind but
ultimately well I mean trying to find a
device to give you that number is not
the goal the goal is to achieve a
particular look and the easiest way to
try to summarize that concisely is by
throwing a number on it just for
communication purposes right like they
they want to look the way that they
believe people look when those people
are at nine percent body fat exactly
whether or not the the look they want to
achieve does actually comport with nine
percent body fat or whether or not they
actually achieve nine percent body fat
it doesn't matter like they're yeah it's
it's the look that they're after yeah
um or just for like one final example
um you know let's say that it's it's not
about sports it's not about Aesthetics
or anything like that you you really are
just trying to to change or improve your
body composition for the goal of health
or graceful aging like you want to lose
some fat to reduce your risk of heart
disease you're trying to build some
muscle or lean mass for you know
graceful aging less risk of like
osteoporosis uh more Independence fewer
issues with activities of daily living
as you get older Etc
like in a situation like that once again
ultimately like changing body comp isn't
the goal improving your health and your
function is the goal so you know
ultimately if like it it doesn't matter
if some method of assessing body comp
says you lost four kilos of fat versus
eight kilos of fat if your blood
pressure is improving your blood lipids
are improving like more direct markers
for like cardiovascular health
you're accomplishing your goal you know
like
um and similarly with like performance
you know
you can you can just assess performance
you know like if you're trying to build
or maintain strength for graceful aging
like
you can you can get on the same machine
at the gym multiple times and like if
you can now use more weight or do more
reps like cool you're accomplishing your
goal like your your musculoskeletal
performance is improving or you're
maintaining it like whatever you're
trying to accomplish so like the the
argument I'm making here
is that very very rarely are changes in
body comp the actual goal someone is
pursuing
um more often than not changes in body
composition are assumed to be and and
often actually are uh assumed to be
associated with the goal someone is
pursuing or predictive of the goal that
someone is pursuing and more often than
not you can assess
something more closely related to the
actual goal you're pursuing with more
accuracy and precision then you can
assess body comp in the first place so
even if we acknowledge that we can't
assess individual level body comp with
a a high or even I would consider an
acceptable degree of accuracy or
Precision we don't actually lose
anything because most of the time that's
not what you actually care about in the
first place so uh yeah just to wrap up
body comp assessments work really well
for groups don't work that well for
individuals
um but that's fine actually yeah so
things people can track obviously track
your body weight uh objective
performance outcomes you know cardio
metabolic depending on what your goal is
there are many things you can track but
even for people who are more physique
focused you can track your body weight
you can you know keep an eye on the
mirror keep you know keep taking
progress pictures limb circumferences
yeah observe how your your clothing fits
I mean like for for physique related
goals like I think that that calipers
are great because I mean all ultimately
the thing that's going to affect the the
visual is assessment of leanness is just
like how little subcutaneous fat you
have like if you don't have much you're
going to look very shredded and calipers
will tell you that yeah so
you know if you
get a Caliper assessment done
whatever body fat number is spat out
when you run those numbers through a
prediction equation doesn't matter but
like you know if your sum of skin folds
has gone down from like 100 millimeters
to like 70 millimeters regardless of
what percent change in body fat that
corresponds with that that is a direct
measure of hey you have less
subcutaneous fat than you had before and
you probably look more shredded yeah I I
was gonna say I think you can go a
really long way if you're like you know
what I accept the content of this
segment but I still really like uh
having some objective quantitative
things I can track I think go a very
long way with a super cheap tape measure
and a cheap pair of calipers and I know
everyone you know like in the exercise
Science World likes to say you basically
have to be a magician to be good at
caliber caliper tests I mean for
research grade purposes sure fine but if
you're just trying to figure you're out
do I have more or less fat over my bicep
than I used to there's YouTube videos
that can teach you the ropes when it
comes to using calipers you can do it
depending on the site maybe yourself
maybe get a friend or someone to do it
for you but just by taking a tape
measure getting a waist measurement
getting limb circumferences getting some
key caliper measurements you can get a
pretty good idea of what is for example
the total size of my bicep looking at
the circumference or I guess my upper
arm and then look at the subcutaneous
fat thickness there's no need to convert
that to a whole body fat percentage that
information tells you exactly what
you're trying to get and you don't have
to stress over you know aiming for these
kind of arbitrary targets like oh no I
I'm doing everything I hope to do but I
wanted to be six percent body fat like I
think keeping your your sights on more
localized measurements is probably ideal
no I I agree and I would also add that
if you're primarily interested in in
assessing body comp for like health
related purposes
like ultimately a waist circumference
measurement or like a waist to height
ratio again not taking a waste to height
ratio and converting that to a body fat
number but just the actual weight to
height ratio number itself that or again
just waste circumference
that that's more predictive of cardio
metabolic Health outcomes than just like
body fat percentages in part because
like as far as health risks go not all
fat is created equal like you can have a
considerable amount of subcutaneous fat
without that having too much of an
impact on cardium anabolic health risks
but like having a lot of visceral fat
not great uh and where's visceral fat
stored in your abdomen around your waist
so you know if if you had two
individuals and you could like perfectly
measure their body fat percentage and
one's 20 body fat with a ton of visceral
fat and one of them's 27 body fat with a
lot of subcutaneous fat and very little
visceral fat like the person at 27 body
fat is probably in in better shape as
far as like health risks go than the
technically leaner person with more
visceral fat but the leaner person with
more visceral fat will probably have a
larger waist circumference whereas the
other person would probably have like
maybe a larger hip circumference or
thigh circumference or something like
that so yeah for for us like a rough
assessment of body comp for health
related purposes just like a away
circumference works great and again like
just take the circumference number you
don't need to worry about converting
that to uh like a rough body fat
percentage number could like that that
doesn't add any additional like useful
or beneficial information